you know before this movie started I
told my friend look every single girl in
this theater is going to scream their
heads off when Jacob inevitably takes
his shirt off because it will happen and
of course it does and every girl of my
theater basically died and then they
didn't watch the rest of the movie which
maybe explains why these movies make so
much money because when girls go to see
it they faint in the middle so they have
to come back and pay for more and then
the movies make a whole bunch of money
they become blockbusters and eventually
we're going to get more than just this
one it's not actually going to be over
there's gonna be even more and I'm gonna
cry now Oh Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn
Part 2 is finally here yay the series is
ending I'm not a twilight hater I'll be
honest with you I don't like the films I
don't but I'm not a hater of them
whatever fans like them they're fun I've
met so many Twilight fans that literally
tell me to my face yeah it's horrible we
just like it we just want to watch it
it's fun and I've come to understand
that a lot of the fans really are like
that some of them really do believe it's
so bad that it's good and they just they
love the whole romance thing and they
just like the whole euphoria of it and
they don't actually care about seeing
quality films and so I kind of
understand it on that level but then
they're all the extreme ones and yeah
we're not gonna talk about that the
point is I'm not a hater of Twilight I
just don't like the movies this movie
starts right where the other one left
off
Bella's transformed now they have a kid
she's a daughter she's growing rapidly
it's a beautiful little CGI baby and
Jacob has imprinted on this baby and
he's in love with the baby and he wants
to protect her and yeah the Volturi or
whatever at the I'm sorry I'm still
laughing about the fact that Jake was a
pedophile moving on the Volturi the big
old clan of vampire people who rule the
world now and their vampire ways they're
not happy because apparently they think
that this baby is an immortal baby an
illegal vampire that was actually born
from two vampires and this thing is
gonna trash everyone because apparently
immortal babies kill everyone and they
explode it's a giant rage fest and the
colons and everyone have to try to
convince the Volturi that no Bella was
actually human when they had this baby
and it's not really immortal and
everything and it leads to this big old
battle and if you're a fan of Twilight
you're gonna love it I don't really know
why you'd be watching this video if you
are a fan of Twilight because you know I
mean just go watch it you're gonna love
it
I mean it's inevitable you will like it
you still think I'm stupid because I'm
telling you that I didn't like it even
if you haven't seen the film yet but I
have that's just how it is with the
people who are like really super
hardcore fans for a material it doesn't
matter what I say if you like it then
you're gonna go and you're gonna like it
that's just how it is you're gonna enjoy
it so go see it for all the rest of us
it sucks
I'll give this movie props though there
is one really good scene in this movie a
battle scene which was a lot of fun and
it was entertaining and there was a cool
little turned around thing that happened
and I won't spoil it for you but it was
cool I like the way they handle it and
it was fun I've never really blamed the
actors in these movies like people are
always like oh Kristen Stewart gives a
horrible performance and Robert
Pattinson is all stoic until Lautner
can't act it off the script for these
movies are just so terrible and the
dialogue is so awful that I can't really
blame any of these actors because
they're all like contractually obligated
to be there and they just got to speak
this dialogue that's absolute crap it's
just a big giant soap opera really and a
lot of these actors don't even want to
be in these movies anymore but now I'm
gonna turn it on okay I'm gonna tell you
guys why I don't like this movie from
the beginning of the movie the freakin
baby is CGI why is this horribly fake
CGI baby just walking around with this
face that the face looks like it's it's
moving like it's not actually attached
to the body
it's a CGI baby why couldn't they just
get a real baby how are you sit when you
have like I don't know two three hundred
million dollars at your disposal to hire
a baby that can act a little bit all the
thing has to do is sit there and go they
have to fricken spend a whole bunch of
money on a CGI face I mean that's just
one little pet peeve alright I think
actually one of my biggest problems with
these movies is the CGI it's not good
like the wolves look cool but whenever
these people run around it just looks so
fake it looks like 1990s television
sci-fi channel special effects there's a
shower Kristen Stewart's running like
really fast and everything and you can
tell the the green-screen and everything
but it just looks so fake and I'm
wondering why they can't spend money to
get good-looking special effects and
look I gotta bring it up okay I know
that fans have defended this story
element and they're gonna defend every
story element in these books no matter
what happens because they love Twilight
Jacob imprinting on a baby is the
creepiest fricking thing I have seen in
a movie all year he's staring at this
little child in love with it and
nicknames it Nessie it's so weird it's
just I don't understand why that's in
there and how these people can come and
sit during this movie and be like this
is so entertaining
Jacob is in love with a baby I'm sorry
shoot me but that's weird do you're a
fan of Twilight you gotta admit that's
weird
okay that's odd and basically the first
like 70 80 90 minutes of this movie it's
just a lot of talking and laughing and
this is funny and the vampires are
coming we have to prepare and really
stir in serious conversations that of
course are super overdramatic and then
the end battle happens and I'm not gonna
lie it was really cool I actually liked
it even though some of the CGI looked
really fake it was a lot of fun but I
think the thing that got on my nerves
the most in this movie is actually a
spoiler since I don't do spoilers in my
videos unless I give you a very fair
warning this isn't really anything big
it's just a scene that happens during
the movie so if you don't really care
okay but just as a warning I'm about to
spoil something so if you don't want to
know that skip to the end or whatever
near the end of the movie Bella and
Edward are sitting together and Bella's
like I I've been practicing and I've
been practicing a new power and I want
to show you something in Edwards all
like and so Bella closes her eyes and
literally makes Edward envision a
montage sequence she makes him envision
a montage sequence of all the previous
films from when they met when they found
loved when they first had sex to all
their experiences in his head so
she she showed him a montage sequence of
the other movies
that's her power is that just really
dumb to anyone else the filmmaker is
obviously one of the fans to see like
their professional version of a fan
video of all of these moments where
they've been in love and everything and
so they decided to give Bella a random
power in which she can envision montages
and show them to Edwards mind so it's
over it's it there's no more maybe I
don't know there might be but look like
I said fans you'll enjoy it go see it
you will poop you'll love it you'll poop
everywhere you'll be so happy and you'll
have fun good for you have fun that's
why late for the rest of us this movie's
not good it is better than part one I'll
give it that but I'm still gonna give
Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn
a d-plus thanks a lot for watching guys
and as always if you like this then you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]